And then what seems to go along with
that is something like truth in
conception and action.
You know,
even people like Jacob who are pretty
damn morally ambivalent to begin with,
get hammered a lot by what they go
through.
And what seems to happen is that they're
hammered into some sort of ethical
shape,
right?
So by the mid point of their life's
journey,
there are people who are solidly planted
who you can trust and who don't betray
being or themselves or their fellow
Matt.
And so it's an interesting,
I mean
it seems reasonable to me to first
assume that you have to establish a
relationship with something that's
transcendent.
It might even be just the future version
of you.
And then second that you have to align
yourself with reality in a truthful
manner.
And that that's your best bet.
And
the biblical stories are actually quite
realistic about that too,
because they don't really say that if
you do that,
you're going to be instantly transported
to the promised land.
Like even Moses,
as we'll find out in the accident,
his stories,
he never makes it to the promised land.
And so it's not like you're offered
instantaneous,
final redemption.
If you move out forthrightly into the
world,
establish a faithful relationship with
being and attempt to conduct yourself
with integrity,
but it's your best bet and it might be
good enough.
And even if it's not good enough,
it's really preferable to the
alternative,
which seems to be something closely akin
to hell,
both personal and social.